recently i got a question from somebody
and said why does it feel like you
always cover crazy lefties why does it
feel like you guys are always talking
about like
these nut jobs on the left or things
like that or these sjws or things like
that here's my thing maybe you you can
attest this in my younger years the ones
who pose a threat to me and the ones who
i got the fights with was like the faux
skinhead types you know the white dudes
who didn't like black people that's
where i was like literally fist fighting
at that meets right yeah you know
literally right right so
that was what i perceived as an issue
back then yeah then i became 18
and i got into the arts
sorry go ahead i'll be honest with you
guys i didn't even know any of this
stuff existed this lgbt trans stuff like
outside of my purview until i joined the
arts because social media wasn't like it
is today once i joined the arts i was
like who the [ __ ] are you people y'all
some weirdos and
what ended up becoming a threat to me
what ended up being calming um the
people who would censor us the people
who would affect us wasn't like the
ultra religious right folks okay it was
these left-wing nut jobs all right these
like sjw types who were like you can't
talk about what happened in ethiopia why
i can't make jokes about what happened
in my own country why can't i talk about
my own experience like these people were
so delusional you know what i mean they
were like pro-minority and also trying
to silence you at the same time it was
[ __ ] nonsense i would watch comics
literally get removed from the scene
because of what some like sjw nut jobs
so when you ask me about what i'm
concerned with or what really affects me
i'll be honest with you it's not ultra
right-wing conservative people it's not
for me anyways okay when i go to
university campus and i can't say [ __ ]
it's not ultra-right-wing conservative
people okay they give you a pyramid
you went like this i thought you were
about to imitate them you you they
because these things they want your life
you know you know you know maslow's
pyramid
maslow's pyramid sometimes you're gonna
you're gonna do you're gonna do shows in
campuses they hand you a pyramid of what
is to say and not to say yeah i'm not
finding skinheads anymore that's not my
reality
i'm not walking down the street with my
belt around my knuckles trying to fight
[ __ ] fend them off that's not
who we fight anymore but they sure want
to fight us whoa
i've had the death threats and it's like
pretty much exclusively from these types
exclusively yeah
yes the type of people black uh i don't
promote violence but i hope you die like
those types okay literally yeah
word for word for [ __ ] words in dm's
not just indians but in real life word
for [ __ ] words i deal with these
people so of course i'm gonna be like
what's wrong with you [ __ ] the
amount of stories from these nut jobs
that i've created not read up online
nothing that distance literally had to
deal with why do you think that a lot of
times we cover
because they're loud in the media that's
the thing that is
trending and their people are talking
about that so their cycles is this [ __ ]
you know what that's the person that
sees that sees that what i see is my dms
and what i see is the comments on every
video on every video there's a comment
that's like why do you cover always
black man why do you cover all man why
do you cover all women we've been called
everything on the book everything
woman hater
man hater blue pilled simp
uh right-wing extremist white
supremacists
western apologists black uh black
supremacists oh tips
we've been called otaps
you know what though if i didn't know
what a hotep was i would say that's cool
because it does sound
like hotep sounds very cool yeah it
sounds that's that's something you see
them there isn't some people yeah then
you hear them on the street like you
guys yeah
but that's the thing is like you look at
the comments on every video
and we're like i call ourselves
the schrodinger's comedians schrodinger
had a theory where he put a cat in the
box for a couple of days and then well
the theory is like until you open the
box the cat is alive and dead
until you open the box and you actually
check for yourself
like he's 50 50. he could be alive he
could be dead we call that schrodinger's
cat you can look it up whatever it goes
a little something like that what i just
said we're schrodinger's comedians we're
everything
i am anti-white anti-black anti-gay
pro-gay pro-white pro-black
i've never been can you say schrodinger
again schrodinger schrodinger
schroedinger
you said that [ __ ] like you turned
brazilian all of a sudden you went up in
dog
up in downing schrodinger
sometimes you pronounce don't think they
kill me
that's pretty much it you know it's like
we're everything so on every video it's
a thing we we covered you you covered
kyle whatever oh you guys all yeah on
this channel is very much pushing to the
right and we can cover the cops oh well
this was
very much the legion of lefties
outside of the art scene i don't
encounter lgbtq people that much
i just don't
you're like you're not just gonna run
across a bunch of trans people all the
time okay go to a vogue competition all
of a sudden they're everywhere go to a
wagging event
it's their event they're not everywhere
that's their event which i'm fine with
but the whole point is that's where
you're gonna start to encounter them
when i go to street dance events that's
when i started to see the story but it's
it's
no comment on that what go ahead
whacking community
wagon community stuff like that and and
i was
entering the vogue community
couldn't do it no
they wouldn't allow me to no
that was not my place to do that it's
not and it's not even everybody in the
vogue community no but it's not
everybody in the whacking community but
the minute i got that comments in the
whacking community like some new people
just came in the scene and we're like
yeah
um
you know your ethereals are showing no
you know as i
they went are you gay they asked me my
attention
why is that an issue if i wanted to
you're fighting
for people not having to ask you and
that everything that is normal but
you're asking me because i've been doing
that dance for like 15 years now 15
almost 20 years now for 16 god damn i'm
old anyways
but i can't do it because oh okay
your whole the whole purpose of what
that was was because it was people it
was acceptance marginalized people could
not fit in
normal society normative normative
society but now i'm from there and i
appreciate y'all and i want to be around
y'all because i think you [ __ ]
are dope as [ __ ] all that culture i i
dig all of that i'm a fan of that and i
i i love it but because i'm like yo
you're a straight black male
but it's literal
it's verbatim what i've been saying a
lot of folks will not understand it
unless they're around it all the time
and i'm like you guys are [ __ ]
weirdos and you know what so folks say
this sometimes they say cancel culture
is not real because like oh or you can't
cancel people who already have so much
wealth or so much influence guys there's
regular people who get cancelled who
you'll never hear about i know because
i've watched them i've watched them get
booted out of comedy entirely i've
watched them get booted out of dance
it really does exist and it really is an
issue
right
yeah i mean you've seen even a dance
the kumbaya oh yeah
is it everything kumbaya yeah yeah yeah
oh peace love and harmony i'm like they
always and and this is a pet peeve of
mine which is personally a big party
they veil everything under the guise of
empathy
it's really authoritarianism they make
the rules follow the rules if you don't
you're a trash person who deserves to be
removed or you're going to be ostracized
that's how it works everything is under
the guise of empathy so when i get up
here we're talking about this understand
there's a background in the history with
it where i'm seeing it every day i'll be
honest with you i don't encounter like
extremist racist white folks all that i
don't see that every day that's not what
i'm dealing with
i'm not saying it's not out there maybe
it's your right that's fine
but if you're asking me what i'm
concerned with it's these weirdos it's a
few of them it's not even it but it's a
few
it's a yeah it's a lie there's a lot of
people in that community that like i
could chill with and i could i i i'm
okay with and that's why i decided not
to say [ __ ] and anything like that
because i don't want to impose myself
you should include everybody including
no if you i don't feel i'm not going to
stay out where i don't feel welcome you
know what i mean so if a [ __ ]
don't want me there i don't want to yeah
it's fine i'm not going to force my
weight to stay there or whatever and
they have a wonderful uh community that
they have and they do it to do anything
i'm just you don't want me to i'm gonna
remove myself from that and that's it
i'm gonna say this to you tell me tell
me if you agree
all right you said it's a few
but because it's a few but you hear me
because it's a few what they do is they
influence the perception and the view of
the folks
and then everyone else kind of just
adopts those things steered about yeah
the direction is over there and and the
other guy's like i'm just trying to sail
so like anything
it's just a couple of us
and then he blow on the [ __ ] sail and
the ship goes that way
so so so that's what it comes down to so
when you guys ask us why it's because of
that i'm like again i'm gonna talk about
stuff that i'm viewing that i'm
concerned with that i'm interested in
that's it you know what i mean like i
don't encounter proud boys i don't
encounter white ring and
identitarianism folks doesn't matter i
don't it doesn't mean i encounter antifa
types
yeah those people they're crazy
they're crazy and they have the same
they have the same uh ammo as the people
i was fighting back in the 90s and
in the 90s the same ammo the same way of
going around just surrounding you and
and cousin rock cause it was the same
thing
i remember there's some people that was
in filtering uh little hip-hop shows at
the end and it was like it was a fight
it was a fight they do the same thing
with riots they do the same thing with
protests peaceful protest
and they instigate it's the same ammo
that's going over it's like the the left
and the right is now i said that before
that left and the right is not a ban
it's not a ban it's a circle and y'all
[ __ ] are right
right there you're right there close to
what they're doing for us it was
literally a bridge a bridge separated
the two bro part of the city and so
literally when you cross the other side
then folks would get jumped on that side
and then if you cross outside they would
get jumped you know what's funny too
literally almost all my political
economical views are all leaning left
i'm for taxation i'm for
socialized healthcare i am pro-choice i
am social programs you know i mean like
i'm for all that stuff there's stuff
that generally identifies with left-wing
folks
right but when it comes to
social things
even that homosexuality gay marriage i
don't care trans rights cool
you want to use the pronouns fine
right you know and then you get to send
another song like yeah maybe go a little
bit too far
but for the most part literally all my
views lean on that side but in terms of
like authoritarianism and like [ __ ]
up my life or making it more difficult
it's all these radical weirdos just
wanted to answer that question so
hopefully you guys understand a little
bit better anything else no yeah let us
know what you guys think you guys agree
do you guys feel like we're too biased
et cetera et cetera let us know what